hello everyone this is amir from
audio science review i thought i
do a quick review of these premium um
headphone cables uh i got a focal Elex
headphone to test the second sample and the
owner was kind enough to send me these uh
add-on accessory cables from a
company called norn audio n-o-r-n-e
audio he sent me three of them this one
i think is the most expensive silver one
you can see it like this a very very soft
supple cable um all three of them are
this is one i think this is could be as
expensive as eight hundred dollars for this cable
um then there's one that i think is a mix
of copper and silver uh braided somehow uh
and then uh he got a maybe thrown in there
because it took a while to get his cables made
and the owner sent him this cable i think
this one's probably about 250 or so he uh
says these cables aren't exactly what's
on the company's website right now but
when i look they're very very close i actually
found three models that were similar to these
and uh i've listed them i've listed the model
numbers in here on the review that i did post
last night yeah i don't know how he pronounces the
drug silver cable and uh and what have you um they
all use you know various types of cables in the
lights configuration i know some people pronounce
lights cables as litz cables i grew up calling
them lights cables i don't know what the proper
German pronunciation is or or whether there's
variation of how people pronounce it in different
English speaking countries anyway these cables
i don't know if you've messed with them they're
very lightweight and have a special twist and when
i used to terminate them back in the day i used to
hate doing that because they're just they have
this insulation you got burned off and then you
got a terminator maul and uh of course somebody
sits there and weaves all these cables like this
so close like knitting or crocheting or something
you gotta sit there and wrap these things and
then you terminate them together and they gotta
sell them properly and hopefully with some kind
of strained relief in there to get them to work
so um as expensive as they sound to me it's uh
you know for one-off type of things doesn't
sound expensive i know i couldn't sell this
cable to you for two hundred dollars and be happy
sitting there in my bedroom making these for you
so it's not a question of cost in here
the question is does it do anything
uh electronically uh electrically or acoustically
um since i recently measured the four calorie
likes uh uh it was not easy to just put it on and
uh i was surprised how well i was able to hold
the headphones in the fixture while unplugging
plugging these cables in because as you do that
the cups can move and just one millimeter movement
can actually change the frequency response
and let me circle back to that so this is
the frequency response of the stock cable
uh in green and then these three cables as you can
see they all land on top of each other the stock
cable from focal is this awful stiff braided cable
that you get maybe excuse me as a i don't know 10
usb cables come that way i have no idea why
company like focal would sell premium k headphones
but comes up with this stiff nonsense so i can see
people from a mechanical point of view wanting a
cable that's as soft and supple as these are
and certainly something that looks better
than what's there but from frequency response
point of view measured acoustically meaning
what was going to go to your ears there's
not even a hair out of place over here
uh it's just incredible how repeatable the
measurements are and despite the fact that
i had to mechanically plug and unplug things
uh if the headphones had moved just a hair
it would have made more of a variation than
these cables have so to give you a sense of how
unreasonable it is to assume that the frequency
once changes every time you put this thing on your
head and take it off you know you're putting it on
differently and you're actually causing frequent
response variations that are measurable but you're
probably not even perceiving that here we can even
measure the effect on this test um the headphone
measurement system automatically spits out
distortions as i show for the headphones and we
can see the different distortion graphs again for
the star cable and blue and then the other three
cables uh on that and these slide variations that
you see in here this is all uh just measurement
differences there's noise in the environment and
and run to run variations actually this is
exceptionally good for headphone measurements
uh the one difference i found was around 120 hertz
which is a double domains frequency of 60hz in us
and it must be radiating from something around
here that i have lots of electronics on my desk
and i was not paying attention to laying the
cable identically so i just randomly measured
i'm not expecting a difference and i noticed that
the stock cable does the best excuse me in this
regard and the three premium cables are actually
slightly worse and picking up that hum and mains
noise um i set up a custom test for that
where i take these cables and i have a
transformer that lets me induce uh electromagnetic
field into the cables and uh i noticed that all of
them pick up some amount uh on that and uh it was
not conclusive maybe the stock cable was a little
bit less but it just wasn't conclusive enough so
i don't you know basically the orientation of the
cable and the source would make it enough more of
a difference than the cable differences themselves
so this just may be a fluke that the other cables
picked up more mains noise or not but it's bad
luck for the company that their cables are the
ones that did worse at least in this one one test
now acoustic measurements are limited in their
resolution because of the noise that exists in
the environment and also the limitation of the
headphone itself the headphone is 1.7 distortion
so let's say these cables have a 0.01 difference
it's not going to show up in here but it is what
we hear it is the application so this is a real
application but to go out of our way and really
focus on the cable itself i bypass the headphone
so i'm still using the top in a90 as the uh
source amplifier headphone amplifier but
instead of connecting the other end of the cable
to a headphone i just hooked it up to my audio
precision analyzer and just measured electrically
what the frequency response would look like and
you can see in here there's just absolutely no
difference this display is extremely zoomed so
only quarter of a db down and quarterly the alps
of the entire range is only half a db even if
we had variations that would fill this graph
it's doubtful that you know you could hear
according to b difference in frequency response
but we don't even have that we have nothing really
it's just as flat as you can get there's a slight
error in here in low frequencies that's just a
measurement artifact and having to average things
out to get rid of noise but essentially what
you're looking at is the frequency response of the
uh headphone amplifier not the cable the all
cables have wider bandwidth than the amplifier
itself and the amplifier itself is great by
the way it's quarter of db down at 60 kilohertz
uh on this thing at 20 kilohertz is it's not even
you know measurable 0.01 db or something like that
so objectively as the physics would say
as everything about electronics would say
they're just you know coming out of two different
ways with a headphone without the headphone
load it just absolutely there's nothing in here
to put put your finger on or hang your head on
and say hey you know this cable can change the
sound frequency response is what dictates tonality
how bright something is how much the mids you're
hearing the bass the impact all that stuff is in
there and non-linearities show up in in distortion
graphs and there's just nothing there at all
now i know better than to finish the review at
this point because the other camp immediately says
wow he didn't listen well okay well listen but
how do you do an a b test of cables you've got to
put the headphone on then you
can't even plug them in blind
really speaking gotta take them off to be able
to see the holes to plug in the cable and put
it back on and then plug it in and play the same
music again by then a minute has gone by and uh
and you put the headphone on differently every
time anyway so no way to from an objective and
proper way of doing control testing can this be
valid because there's just too much interruption
there and but we did the test anyway when i
said we my son is in his 20s and it's got a
much better sensitivity his first level than that
i do and neither one of us could hear a difference
uh on that thing uh now obviously people say
they hear night and day difference or they hear
i don't know some level of difference it's the
standard explanation i've given in the past
and that your brain listens differently you change
cables and you listen differently you may think
it sounds better you may think it sounds worse
you absolutely hear a difference because you're
focusing differently on music you're not a machine
you're not like my measurement gear and every time
you apply yourself you apply yourself differently
that's why we do the test blind um when you don't
know something's changed or not and then we
can see statistically whether you were just
coming up with these things and the same thing
would apply to both cables if we did it blind
but when you do the test cited then you
know what you're switching and what have you
and you just can't arrive at any kind of reliable
conclusion that there is a difference your brain's
ability to manufacture differences is probably
a hundred to a thousand times more than this
cable possibly could even if it had a difference
and but there isn't it's just uh you know they
they just sounded the same i mean there's i
don't know what else to tell you the physics say
that the electronics say the theory says that
the research says that measurements say that
every arrow points to any statement of audible
difference to be wrong or at best hugely unlikely
the fact that somebody ad hoc says oh i can hear
it it's like great go ahead and do a blind test
where you have somebody put the headphones on you
without you seeing them and have them change the
cables behind you and do that 10 times see if you
get at least 8 out of 10 right until you do that
then you're just letting your eyes and your state
of mind and and perception guide you as opposed to
real truth on these things now there's no denying
that these cables feel better i didn't try to wear
them long term but just touching them you want
to sort of play with them and wrap up they feel
nice and they seem well built uh because you're
braiding so many cables uh on this thing and if
they give you joy in having them and you can get
them custom lengths and what have you get it as
i said at the outset i don't think this person's
you know gouging people on this thing i don't know
how much silver cables cost and what have you
but i know that sitting there in your home and
putting up at the misery of making cables
is not fun and then dealing with customers
and selling them and taking returns and building
and shipping all that stuff so personally i don't
have an issue with the cost or the business
model and i understand my understanding that
this person lives in silicon valley hugely
expensive place to live and and try to pay
mortgage payments and get some food so uh it's not
a religion i have against companies like this and
in case of focal if i own those headphones the
standard stock cord would drive me nuts and i
would get something else but you know if you
want to go with this company's cables i would
get the cheapest ones you can and 200 ones
are you know same connectors at each end and
they look fine too although i don't know if i
like this color but otherwise they're fine so
um just you know objectively we test this stuff
so that when somebody says how do you know they
don't sound different well we've we've tried you
know we've tried it our way we tried it their way
with listening tests and there's no difference
now if you want to say that i don't hear as well
i'm happy to pass a challenge that for both of
us to take on what your ability is to hear the
differences and that starts with you first showing
blind that you can tell the difference is that
easy and that obvious just don't look when you
uh tell us which is which and see where you are
you know it's a good opportunity to get educated
on these things and if you're on the fence and
you know you haven't dived into this topic i
highly encourage you to look at results like this
and know that everything we know about science and
engineering points to the results that i have to
be true but we still spend the energy and time and
expense of shipping these cables back and forth
just to have some hard data behind our
opinion so that we don't just have you
know my word we have my word then we have
data we have research the other side wants
to counter this then they need to go beyond
their work they gotta have their research
okay hope you found some of this useful
and i'll see you in a future video bye